[Music]
our series of more perfect union names
to show that what unites us as americans
is far greater than what divides us
and every year the nfl donates to cities
that host the super bowl
striving to make a difference that will
last long after the confetti falls and
this year
that help is needed more than ever we
can all agree mark straussman shows us
now
how the nfl and tampa the super bowl's
host committee
there created a new program called
forever 55
and it's already changing lives they
came looking for food
starting last april their desperation
peaking with a pandemic
500 cars day after day outside
metropolitan ministries
in tampa for many hunger gave way to
homelessness 40 of the folks that were
in that line
were first-time folks who never needed
our help before you're trying to
stabilize a family in crisis
absolutely and what we do at
metropolitan ministries is help them
navigate out of that crisis towards
self-sufficiency
100 families in crisis have temporary
housing here
90 percent led by single working moms
like tracy lewis what was the lowest
point i was
eight months pregnant walking up and
down outside like i ain't got nowhere to
go
what's going to happen am i going to
have to stay outside with the baby
metropolitan ministries gave lewis
housing they helped reunite her with
three daughters living in jamaica but
without a car
getting to work is a struggle that's
where the nfl came in
the league pledged two million dollars
to tampa nonprofits
like metropolitan ministries which
identified
20 families in need we'll come up with a
custom program for each family
and really take them over the hump and
really be a part of a legacy to our
community
tracy lewis got the car she needed a
2020
ford escape i wasn't even expecting a
brand new car i just wanted something
that would take me
to and from it's really a blessing to
have if the nfl is looking
in part to leave a legacy in tampa
you're the legacy
hi alexia shepard fled with her two kids
from an abusive relationship
but even dumpy hotels became
unaffordable when she ran out of money
last october
so we were living in my car for two days
two kids in a car sleeping a lot of
crying a lot of praying
a lot of i didn't ask a lot of whys
but i was like don't ask why just fix it
her resilience also struck derek brooks
the former tampa bay buccaneers
linebacker
and co-chairman of the super bowl host
committee man you just respect her
gritting her grind
as a single parent to never give up on
herself and never give
up on her kids lewis needed a permanent
place to live
until now whoa
this is beautiful
wait this is our apartment it's yours
for the furniture furniture
no this is you
oh my god
oh my god i'm sorry
affordable housing a brand new
three-bedroom apartment
no one should have to live in a car
it's a little overwhelming isn't it it's
overwhelming but i think that
i think y'all that is this super bowl's
legacy
it will live in tampa long past whoever
wins the big game
on sunday it's a beautiful legacy what
is better than life change
for 20 families that have come out of
homelessness
now that tracy lewis has a car she's
saving to rent a house
later this year and alexia shepard is
studying to become a nurse
the nfl will also cover her tuition 5500
tony incredible story mark yeah amazing
program as well
but i like what she said mark don't ask
why just fix it
don't ask why just fix it and then her
her clear
uh emotion when she said i get the
furniture too
when you don't have when you don't have
money that's what that's your mind goes
right there right away
and yes yes and what and what so
encourage you about this it's not a
momentary fix it's you can tell this is
this is going to
literally sustainable changes people's
lives